[Music]
concave polynomials which are some of
which six appeared in a Nima's talk this
so this is joint work with Hema quickly
and Cheyenne and in honor of the
hyperbolic workshop at least the
beginning definitions with respect to a
general convex cone sort of coordinate
free but then you know the meanings for
them all the main examples the convex
cone OB then non negative work so if you
want to let's take to be a convex
and we'll take a polynomial with real
coefficients and end variable and one of
the properties so before we go to
complete la concavity and start with log
concavity which already appeared so
we'll say that f
F is logged concave not gonna preheat
I'll see on this coned
if F is positive on the relative
interior of the cone meaning that we can
take it makes sense to take the log
evaluate the log of f and concave
on this sort of but which I really want
to mean that the the Hessian evaluated
at any point on the relative interior is
negative semi definite valuated at any
point relative interior the con is
negative semi definite
Oh
[Music]
and again for the example to have in
mind
it worked
so this is some property which and we'll
say that it's completely law concave if
not only the polynomial has this
property but all of its directional
derivatives have this property where I'm
allowed to take directions coming from
that call
okay we're all vectors
take any M vectors then the I take
directional derivatives with respect to
all those those vectors the resulting
polynomial is either identically zero or
log concave
so here this notation D sub B I really
mean the directional derivative some
so as a quick example so the the
quickest way to get an example of such a
thing is to take a univariate real
rooted polynomial all of whose roots are
negative I claimed so RI
negative real numbers I claim that this
is such a polynomial so they do in fact
exist and if I have such a polynomial so
if I want to check if it's log concave I
take it blog and I take two derivatives
if you imagine taking the log of this it
turns into a sum taking you know one
derivative I get a bunch of reciprocals
I could take two derivatives to be
something that's not negative
that's our non negative
negative on the on the positive always
and so this is so the function log is
concave on the positive Ortman and
moreover if I take I start with any
polynomial that's real rooted with
negative roots and I take a derivative
of it the derivative will have the same
property derivatives of real rooted
polynomials are real rooted and the the
roots really have to interlace so this
will so the derivative of F will have
the same property which means that it
will be locking and as one one might
expect and we've seen so far if I have a
hyperbolic polynomial that is back to
some vector eat
then we've already seen that is located
on its hyperbola speak on the steel
Avant's notation ELISA become so the the
log of a hyperbolic polynomial forms a
nice barrier function for its comb for
the hyperbola city cone and so in
particular it's log is a common forms of
concave function on this cone and
moreover if I start taking directional
derivative take some vector in life of
olicity cones
and it's directional derivative is again
hyperbolic with respect to Z and the
corresponding cone gets bigger
servile is becoming the derivative so in
particular since this polynomial is long
concave on its own hyperbola city cone
it's a long concave on the smaller
hyperbola yes maybe too early for data
you should also make sense for functions
not just for now minutes yes you're
welcome to use this definition for
functions and I will I don't think I'll
be able to tell you any theories for
resulting before that but yeah it would
be interesting to yeah all of this makes
sense for functions
[Music]
and so if you take if you keep taking
directional derivatives and will find
that that is okay on its hyperbole
in particular in the special case where
our cone is the non- orphaned this
really corresponds to stability so we
have a genius
I know me I love degree D and n
variables then F is hyperbolic respect
to the vectors in the positive or thumbs
if and only if it is stable
which will then imply that it's
completely concave on the non-negative
worth it just for a very explicit
example of this happening they have to
be the product of just the variables
beautiful stable polynomial and by
taking for example directional
derivatives with respect to the all ones
vector we start getting elementary
symmetric polynomials stable hyperbolic
with respect to the positive or sent and
that's an easy for you to do and if I
start taking directional derivatives I
get elementary symmetric polynomials
constant multiple and hypervelocity
cones get bigger so the hypervelocity
cone of the first polynomial is just a
non-negative or thent which i will slice
and and draw here and if i take a
derivative
[Applause]
and so the main main takeaway for this
conference at least is that this
whatever this condition is it is a
generalization of hypervelocity for
polynomials and it turns out to be
satisfy a lot of the same properties and
have nice applications of which Nima
mentioned
and we'll see the it doesn't fill up our
stable polynomials do not fill up the
set of all completely log compute some
bigger some bigger occasion
so for now I want to restrict back to
when the cone is be non negative work
and make some relatively basic
observations about what this implies so
if we think about log concavity on this
cone I claim that it's preserved under
some fairly simple operations for
example I can scale all of the variables
and I can scale the polynomial
[Music]
it's really just that the non negative
or think is closed under these things we
can have to be a closed set
in the real vector space let's say is in
the cone of polynomials of some degree
with non-negative coefficients
and using these two relatively simple
properties we can actually take initial
forms so if I have some polynomial start
right out in the monomial basis
and it's law concave on the non- orth
and then so is its initial form by which
I mean I'm going to I have some some
weight vector W and what I'm going to do
is I'm going to pick out all of the
monomials that maximize that weight
vector
and the the reason I can do this is I
can really view this as a limit of
polynomials so I can view this I have
some weight vector of a polynomial I can
imagine taking my polynomial and
multiplying it by you know t to the W
want X 1 X n that equality is not true
yet for some parameter T and what that
does is it will scale the the monomials
X to the Alpha by T to the W transpose
alpha and then if I sort of divide
through by the highest power of T that I
find brihat I shouldn't use D you to the
degree in W of this polynomial and take
the limit as T gets really big then I'm
gonna pick out exactly at the initial
form
and so this is what this lets us start
to understand something about what type
of polynomials they are these art and in
particular what their supports and what
their newton polytopes can look like you
know the Newton polytope of a palette of
a polynomial it's really you take all of
the exponent vectors that appear plot
them as vectors in R to the end and take
the convex hull and what taken initial
form does is pick off a face of that
poly tope that maximizes the linear
function as we took the second
elementary symmetric polynomial in four
variables
where IJ range over all subsets size to
of one through four then the Newton
polytope will be a a polytope in r4 but
it will live in the hyperplane given by
all the coordinates x equal to and will
actually get an octahedron
namely the convex hull of all 0-1
vectors with exactly two ones octahedron
and if we picked up with we pick off we
can pick off faces of this if we take
one zero zero zero that says we'll pick
out all of the things with the highest
degree in X one polynomial that's just
going to be all over the terms with an X
1 right so I'll get X 1 times I pick and
that is really I'm taking let's do a
color
this defines a function on this on this
ponytail and I'm picking off the face
this correspond these monomials
correspond to the face of the polytope
it gets maximized by this one similarly
I can pick off an edge I take you know I
really want to take x1 and then I want
to sort of I'm interested in x2 and x3
and equal measures I'm not that
interested in x4 so then I get that's
maximized because that linear function
maximizes some edge
and so in particular what this means
that we can take initial forms and
preserve this property of being law and
concave on the non negative or thin
these much tinier polynomials also must
be logged concave and so for example if
we want to characterize what faces we
can understand you know maybe what
polytopes show up as Newton polytopes of
well concave polynomials by
understanding smaller ones
by understanding faces and in particular
it turns out to be very useful to try
and understand the edges that show up in
such a Newton polytope so for example
encourage you to sit down and try and
show is that if you have a polynomial
with just two terms positive
coefficients
then this polynomial is Balog concave on
the none whenever I don't write a cone
it'll de cone is a non-negative Worthen
if and only if these monomials only
differ by a little bit so if and only if
the the difference difference and the
exponent factors either as plus minus 1
0 vector with exactly one non-zero entry
and in fact if you start with exactly
the type of polynomials that Nemo was
using so if we start with a polynomial
Multi offline and homogeneous so sum
over all subsets let's say one through
end of sum
and the mutant poly type of this is a
zero one vector
exactly the indicator it's the conduct
holds the indicator functions indicate
your vectors of s where C's the best is
nonzero or thent then all edges of the
Newton polytope are parallel to e I
minus J because we take the initial form
if we pick out an edge using a weight
vector we're gonna get a polynomial of
this form if it's homogeneous then
you're really going between sexes of the
same size so the only thing you can do
is swap two elements for example here if
we look at any of these edges there are
always edges between it so these are the
indicator vectors of all subsets of size
two of one through four and if I look at
the actual edges subsets corresponding
to two edges they come from doing
flipping exactly two elements for
example I don't have an edge between the
top vertex 1 1 1 2 0 sorry that
corresponds to the subset 1 2 and the
bottom vertex that correspond to the
subsets 3 4 and I'm not allowed to
because I have to swap two element I
have to swap out take away two elements
and add two elements to to get to them
and in particular using
one one of the many beautiful
characterizations of Metroid's this
implies that the support of a subsets
with nonzero coefficients these are the
basis of a meteoroid
so this I will get and wait five minutes
two minutes yeah so this is yes so so
far this story look should look very
familiar from the four people who know
about stable polynomials this is this is
very familiar this was just using a
theorem by I didn't write down the names
of Jesus Galvan McPherson and Sarah Nova
that you can tell if you're a mate roit
if someone gives you a bunch of zero one
vectors and you want to know if they're
the indicator vectors of some may tried
what you can do is you can take the
convex hull and check and if every edge
is is parallel to a I minus AJ then you
started off with a mate right and vice
versa it's really a characterization of
Metroid's and in particular for for real
stability this was already known this
was done by Joey Oxley Sokol and Wagner
around 2004 was that if you have if this
polynomial is real stable then the
support of the polynomial are the basis
of a Metroid and one of the slightly sad
things but it's true is that not all
major roads show up this way
not sorry for the stable version so
first ability
and sadly not all Metroid's meteoroids
comm is the support polynomial for
example Peter
Brendan showed that the fan Oh metroid
is an example where it's perfectly good
perfectly good may try it but there is
no real stable polynomial whose support
matches the fan ohm Android and more
generally so this was for homogeneous
multi affine polynomials again work of a
Peter sort of characterized more general
combinatorics going on for for stable
polynomials are not necessarily multi a
fine and for the corresponding statement
of or for these polynomials and I
defined a particular type of polyhedron
so I'll take ya Pisa generalize for me
to keep
if all of its edges parallel plus or
minus
and so the main here's one of the things
we can say about completely a lot of
concave polynomials sort of extending
extending this idea is if you have some
polynomial and it is completely law
concave on the non-negative word so then
it's Newton polytope is a generalize
permit a hydrant and the support is
really every integer vector
moreover and this is where there's sort
of you know there's a large gain over
the the theory of real stable
polynomials any integer generalized
permute ahed Rijn has a real stable
polynomial
for any
we meet integer integer vertices
the following polynomial so I sum over
all integer points
overall integer points
scale according so I sum up all of the
monomials in my polytope scaled
appropriately by the dividing by the
product of the factorials sort of
multinomial coefficient this is
completely locked concave in particular
if I take any may trade it gives me a
perfectly good it gives me a perfectly
good generalized permuting engine and
for a zero one factor I really get the
generating polynomial of metroid so for
example the fant the generating
polynomial of the Fano metroid is
completely law concave on the non-
portland but it is not real
for example all of the approximations
that approximation algorithms that one
wants to run on problems on mate roids
I think previously there was a lot of
work in the case where the may trades
where especially the generating
polynomial the mate ride was real stable
but then it runs into this problem but
you know you don't get all of all mate
rides this way and so one of the sort of
strengths of this class of polynomials
is that one can do a lot of the same
things run a lot of the same
approximation algorithms that worked for
real stable polynomials but it includes
sort of for example all all mate roids
you get sort of a nice combinatorial a
class of polynomials that plays nice
with the combinatorics that you want
happy with
everything good even I know that it's
the support of a completely level
[Applause]
one of the other sort of nice things
that has occurred with this class of
poem is is that you can actually it's
not that bad to actually test if you
have one so we just saw James told us on
Monday that no do you some day ago that
that it's actually and be hard
Tuesday to to test hyperbola City and
and I think that is bared out by you
know many of our experiences in practice
where you have some polynomial and you
want to know hyperbolic it's not always
so easy in practice to do either
and so one benefit of these is actually
you can actually test that both suppose
you're handed some polynomial with
non-negative coefficients
that's how a genius of degree D
following things are equivalent
one is that F is concave on the non
negative work so the condition that we
want to which I'll put in is that is
Lorenz Ian and but the last or these
three is the one that is the checkable I
could make this list longer but one one
sort of what I consider a friendly only
condition is that one the we should have
the the support should be correct so we
should have the Newton polytope of F
should be generalized for me to Hadrian
the support really should be its support
should fill up should be all of the
integer points
so there's some condition on the support
and then the last thing is that okay
Mirko says it's okay and he's in the
back so we'll we'll go ahead if you take
derivatives in in coordinate directions
until you get a polynomial so no genius
of degree two this is stable
for all so for all all vectors of size
and really by this I mean alpha I'm
using a shorthand for you know take the
derivative with respect to X 1 alpha 1 x
and so really what this says is that all
right you there's some condition on the
support and this can be phrased in
several different ways and then what you
need to do is you need to take some
finite sum you know big but finite
number of quadratics that you get by
taking derivatives of your various
derivatives of your polynomial and check
if they're stable and for quadratic
polynomials with UV so we saw for cubics
health in five to forty three variables
it's hard for quadratics this really
just means that
but this means that the defining
quadratic form
exactly one positive eigenvalue or
rather it has lured the Lorenz e'en
signature plus one plus and then the
rest - isn't zeros
first lines are necessary you can
replace them with other things but you
cannot you cannot get rid of them
altogether for example if you had so
this is this is really just getting down
to quadratics right so this is so for
example if I had there's a nice cubic
beautiful polynomial and if I took so
what if I ignored this and I said how
should I check if it's completely log
concave this says I am allowed to take I
have to take all derivatives to get down
to a quadratic so here that would mean
taking the derivative with respect to
every variable and check if those
quadratics and that condition is
satisfied right if I take for example
the
one app I just get perfectly good stable
polynomial and similar if I take the
derivative with respect to any of the
others I just get a product of two
variables which is a perfectly good
stable polynomial it comes in here I
mean this is really the history since
six five I was right Padgett isn't six
variables so you don't this zero so
there's a lot of zeros they're positive
or negative or you don't care
so the Hessian so this will give a rank
to Hashem
we'll just have a one in the two three
spot and the three two spot and a zero
everywhere else it'll be a rank this one
one and suspended ceiling right so yeah
which is good that's this is good yeah
it passes this test you want Street I
want one strictly positive eigenvalue I
I want this polynomial be stable if you
like stable polynomials that's the
that's the condition I want this
polynomial to be stable this is a
perfectly good stable polynomial so it
passes it passes this test but it does
not pass
and this is good because this is not so
this polynomial is not log concave on
then on the non negative
it's also not the support of a mate
right Newton polytope is it's very much
not what we want so this is this is this
part is necessary there's lots of
different ways to get to it so Peter and
Jonah have sort of independently
developed this class of polynomials and
they get to basically the same condition
via a different route but you need
something
[Music]
say ball
okay but a fans not
so if you have if you know your true so
if I wanted to prove that I think I
would try and prove that means that you
I don't think it's this quite full but
it might be sort of big enough like you
can chop off the diagonal you can always
chop off the
if it's enough it because it implies all
this other stuff yeah good yeah okay I
have to I think I have to two minutes
it's dangerous to have you chair because
we know that you just you know you
taught us to just power through okay so
so one of the so maybe I'll just go for
ideas of whatever has left so one of the
ideas of a lot of these equivalences is
you can really reduce you can reduce
this fairly hard looking condition of
log concavity with respect to taking you
know all directional derivatives on all
of the cone with some additional
condition you can really you can really
get away with taking directional
derivatives with expect to like the
extreme rays of this cone for example
the non-negative or thent you can really
get away with taking this is directional
derivatives with respect to the extreme
rays of this cone and
and just too so that it's written down
at least once really the connection
between
well concavity and signature property
it's really if you take the Hessian of
the log vs we ignore the F square in the
denominator this is and we evaluate at a
point we get a constant times a matrix
minus a rank one vector and we want this
to be negative semi definite when
evaluated at all points of the non
negative orphaned and what this is going
to mean as this means that this matrix
as a quadratic form will have to be
negative semi definite on the orthogonal
complement of this
what about all of this evaluated at some
point on hyperplane given by this
polynomial and that will imply for that
it has oculars thing is that one can go
back so it seems to be a nice set of
polynomials there's still you know some
some properties of hyperbola city extend
very nicely some it is unclear how to
extend them very nicely or if they do
among other thing they include a lot of
nice combinatorial examples like the
general base of generating fundamentally
[Applause]
a question about these statements of
type polynomial homogeneous polynomial P
is completely both concave and convex
concave so for fixed concave you showed
us that there are completely completely
algorithmically concave polynomials that
are not necessarily stable so now I
would like to focus on the convex cones
that you get is the domains so all the
examples that I was able to keep track
they happen to be my probabilistic cones
so are there examples of are there
examples of completely low concaved
homogeneous polynomials who are so on a
convex cone that's not hyperbole speaker
I mean one could always take a subset of
a cone right like I could take my
favorite non hyperbola Sadiq Khan and
stick it into the non negative orphaned
in the sand statics when you take the
wall yeah I'm thinking in terms of
optimization right sort of it's not to
you true that if you can optimize over a
convex optimization problem or this
course of convex cones it's not
necessarily true that you could optimize
over every substance of their code yeah
I well so one thing that we don't know
is what how to enlarge once you have a
cone so if you have a hyperbolic
polynomial and it's hyperbolic with
respect to a point just am usually old
point then it turns out you get a
beautiful convex cone and it's
hyperbolic and is unique you get a cone
and for these polynomials you know you
start with some cone log concave with
respect to that cone for example the non
negative orphaned and it's very tempting
to try and enlarge it
I think it's unclear what the correct
way to do that is so I think that
if that part of the story is not it's
not clear if hey Peters finished it yes
the question so you can so if you have
this definition then you can of course
look at maximum and are there like
finally many maximal comes but for
Lawrence well for for a company clean
local people to represent polynomials
this maximum comb is not unique how bad
they not unique very badly non unique
well
there might be some other definition of
me but you know all right so that's the
you know so far I think what you want to
ask is what's the hypervelocity : and so
far there might not be a we don't now
have a good set to optimize I'm the
Droid convex Khan to optimize I mean the
thing is there's an actual domain where
I require is positive so when you write
log P or something right so that does
define a comb just just because when it
disco mix is always hyperbolic when it's
convex I don't know of an example of him
but I would be very surprised if you
ride around his house yeah so far I
think the cone is corn isn't a mystery
only the support condition the following
kind suppose I take the interior
coefficients and I make them more
positive when I stay skills
some versions the interior lattice horns
have to be in the support yeah like that
the statement that says suppose I take
these interior coefficients and I
somehow make them even large and I stay
seals you can't just I don't think you
can do it willy-nilly but I think that
there it's I find it very plausible that
there's a careful way to so that so
maybe the thing that band is is
implicitly referring to is that this
condition you do get some sort of nice
discreet or almost discrete concavity
conditions on the coefficients and it's
very plausible that if you somehow make
them more discreetly logged concave that
you stay in this that's I think you
would need to do it carefully and but I
don't have I you know yeah I don't
personally have a statement
but I find it plausible what can you say
about the zero sample I asked to the I
asked to the audience what can you say
about the the zero set of a computer law
concave polynomial I think in general
not much I think it you know they're
done well I mean there was a session the
conclusion was that for instance for
sofa bankers law degree the topology can
be what degree six four or five six okay
so plane curves polynomials and three
that homogeneous polynomials three
variables degree four or five six the
real zero set can have any topology not
I don't think they necessarily all have
to have a common interlace ER but but
you get to them by common interlacing so
so in the if you have quadratics
yeah so if you you could you can
basically go from this condition to
something like this by using something
like common interlaces and really the I
think that
well okay well put us so one potential
definition of interlacing you know maybe
we want G to interlace well put quotes
because it's not actual interlacing cuz
the topology is you know who knows what
interlaces F is really that when you
take enough derivatives directional
derivatives down to quadratics say you
take derivatives this will be a linear
form if if this is say degree D and this
is degree D minus 1 then the linear form
you get to will interlace the quadratic
stable polynomial this is potentially a
good definition of for all vectors
there's so far in terms of the pictures
that you want to draw a lot for
hyperbolic combos you want to draw
pictures the pictures you want to draw
what you have to do is you have to get
down to quadratics and then Europe then
you have stable polynomials you can draw
pictures and so I think that all the
pictures that I've been able to draw
have been sort of going down to
quadratics and that's that's in
particular derivatives derivatives will
satisfy this property
[Applause]